Monsieur Alain
geste merci monsieur le Président ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur le Premier
Ministre après avoir au début du
quinquena pratiquer un matraquage fiscal
sans précédent votre majorité même si ce
terme ne signifie plus grand-chose
aujourd'hui a menacé à de a annoncé à de
multiples reprises que le gouvernement
se lançait dans un vaste plan d'économie
pour réduire les déficits la réduction
en réalité été fort modeste en 2015 de
l'ordre de 0,4 points du produit
intérieur brut le solde public comme la
dette de notre pays sont donc demeurés
plus dégradés que ceux de la plupart des
pays de la zone euro vous avez néanmoins
annoncé un objectif de réduction du
déficit à 2,7 % en 2017 mais nos
compatriotes constatent jour après jour
une avalanche de dépenses nouvelles au
gré des mouvements sociaux ou des cadeau
tous aimut accordé par le Président de
la République dans sa recherche
désespérée de conquête de son électorat
ces dépenses sont évaluées à 6 milliards
d'euros la liste est tellement longue
que je ne l'illustrerai que que par
quelques exemples plan d'urgence pour
l'emploi plan élevage dégel du point
d'indice de la fonction publique mesures
pour les jeunes crédit demandeur d'asile
en augmentation prime pour les
enseignants et cetera et cetera je
pourrais y ajouter les conséquences de
l'échec des négociations unédiques et
les
sous-budgétisations conséquence la
trajectoire de limitation des déficits
connaît une véritable embardée ce n'est
pas notre groupe qui le dit c'est la
Cour des comptes dans son rapport annuel
publié ce matin où sont les économies
pour financer certaines de ces mesures
sans doute utiles je sais bien que votre
Ministre des Finances évoque toujours la
fameuse réserve de précaution en CLIRE
le gère des crédits mais là encore la
Cour des comptes insiste sur les limites
de l'exercice surtout lorsque le
président la République revient sur
certains arbitrages alors Monsieur le
Premier Ministre malgré vos Prom monur
Christian secrétaire d'État chargé du
budget monsieur le Président mesames
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
àin geste je vous propose de nous
rajeunir un peu pas forcément pas
forcément pour en revenir à la période
2007-2012 où la dépense publique
augmenté de 3 et5% non seulement d'une
année monsieur le député il
jour pour jour les mêm sur les mêmes
bans nous annoncer l'apocalypse pour
l'exercice 2015 il nous disait il
manquera 10 milliards il nous disait
votre objectif de 3,8 et la Cour des
comptes ne disait pas autre chose votre
objectif de 3,8 % risque de ne pas être
atteint et bien il a été de 3,6 %
c'està-dire un déficit inférieur à nos
prévisions nous examinerons lundi
monsieur député la loi de règlement pour
l'exercice 2015 et aujourd'hui vous nous
parlez des dépenses de 2017 nous sommes
en juin 2016 le débat d'orientation des
finances publiques n'a pas eu lieu
monsieur le député nous vous
transmettrons dans les prochains jours
les arbitrages que le premier ministre
rendra dans les prochaines heures sur
nos prévisions de dépenses
2017 et soyez rassuré monsieur le député
le B d'orientation des finances
publiques vous permettra d'apprécier que
les dépenses annoncées par le Président
de la République ou par d'autres pour
2017 seront parfaitement intégrés dans
notre trajectoire et qu'avec une
prévision de croissance raison vous les
avez pas reçu encore monsieur Mariton et
donc vous le vérifierez avec une
prévision de croissance que chacun
sa'acorde à dire raisonnable l'objectif
de 2,7 % fin 2017 est maintenu alors je
comprends votre impatience rendez-vous
jeudi mais que votre impatience ne se
transforme pas en suspiss ou en
angoisse merci Monsieurr écker la parole
est à Madame